like if you would have told 17 year old
me that my creation would be in the wild
in a Toys R Us it'd be it would be very
I had very big Ambitions and I thought
and continue to think I could do
anything but um that one would have hit
that one would have hit the real way
[Music]
so many people underestimating how scary
it may get in the next three to six
months with the macro economy get
thoughtful look at that credit card
statement and see how many things you're
paying for each month doing whatever the
[ __ ] you do to cope with hating your job
how about spending those hours after the
job that you hate because you have bills
to pay I get it and responsibilities to
figure out how the [ __ ] to get out of it
see what people understand about content
creating is
when done right it's not even about your
intended or current audience
it's empowering your intended and
current audience to contextualize it
within their world and then give it to
their audience content creation when it
comes from good intent
is just absurd it lives forever how
about the piece of content I made
yesterday that didn't hit and 19 and a
half years from this second somebody
that really matters grabs it
re-contextualizes it
and it does hit you're never out when
you put out good content
it's never over
there have been people here since the
opening of our doors this morning is
that right that's insane I'm so humble
so humbled
real man this is unbelievable I'm very
humbled on Dan Peterson official on uh I
know exactly pink logo I know exactly
who you are what you have done for
people globally is on just ungodly and
um it's trickled down now second
generation
on to my kids because I'm preaching the
same stuff to them gratitude perspective
and it's starting to make a difference
and it's a special man I really
appreciate you seeing that brother
that's something that more people need I
agree it's why I built a whole universe
because I'm just one man but with three
characters I can build infrastructure
for many years after I'm around yeah
it's it's really crazy this is surreal
thank you brother I'm very flattered oh
my god I've never seen one of these open
here we go dust my first blind box you
get to open it
I've not seen one of these open
let's go
epic
I opened I I bought six I opened five
and that's the sixth one
[ __ ] crazy it's crazy to me like
after all my years of collecting things
like this for that to be out of my mind
that out of my own head it's unreal yeah
of course
appreciate you appreciate you back
brother I'm 25 and like I'm a DJ but
also working as building a media
production company like when you're in
like two things for the heads how do you
foot what do you give your most
attention to whatever the [ __ ] I want to
get my attention to yeah there's no
right answer to focus yeah
if you're in the mood to focus on DJing
for three weeks you do that yeah yeah
and then you get like oh [ __ ] my
production company like people think
there's a [ __ ] rule on Focus right
focus on where the [ __ ] you want to
focus on I do thank you man got you
Emily nice to meet you so I me and my
business partner just founded a creative
agency and like my business partner is
doing amazing on like the networking
front like great like he's making so
many connections and stuff but I like
have a really hard time like networking
and stuff like do you have any advice of
like how to like start conversations
like how to like just get better at Like
Making Connections the only way to get
better at networking is realizing why
you're scared of people's judgment it's
it's something I deal with like my hope
it's not about a technique it's why do
you actually worry that if Dustin you
come up to him and want to network him
and he's like no why does that make you
feel bad you need to figure that out
exactly that's right let me give you the
secret yeah it doesn't [ __ ] matter
[ __ ] Dustin yeah right just saying [ __ ]
you Dustin say it was good it'll make me
happy it'll make it'll make my day
it's like a photo if you can remember
that moment and realize all of them are
Dustin yeah it's not like [ __ ] you
really it's like don't value someone's
opinion about you more than the value
that you put on yourself about you I
know I got to I gotta do this so start
practicing what happens next you
practice okay you like really practice
yeah you just go and actually Network
and just do it and like feel the pain
and the awkwardness until it's gone okay
yeah thank you so much you're welcome so
uh my parents just retired and then I'm
basically their like retirement account
yeah like financially so how do you deal
with the fact of you know the pressure
of having to like give their money
possibly I see it's fine but I don't
know like what to do they say it's fine
as in if you don't got it yeah so are
you putting on that pressure yourself
they don't have the money though
but are you are you
have to rule that your ego is not being
tied up in it
because if they're willing to live
humbly based on the reality of their
finances
you may be putting on just pressure and
building unjust resentment towards them
based on your ego
wanting that for you
bro it might be that I didn't think
about it that's a curveball right yeah
well you I didn't get here by my looks
dude I'm telling you there's a lot in
there all right all right I'll work on
it work on that I'll tell you that the
hustle video literally like the single
most motivated piece of content I've
ever seen so I was going through some
stuff and it really yeah like that man
you know it's so funny like people a lot
of my friends ask me like why I still do
the content because they think I should
worry about all this other stuff that
can make me money and I'm like if they
understood what that sentence to me from
you feels like it's better than every
[ __ ] people are so confused about what
life's about thank you for saying that
means a lot to me bro you're gonna die
it was a close time yeah bro that one
really [ __ ] with me like it's real like
I don't think people realize I had to
wear it that's [ __ ] good [ __ ] I got
it from Instagram I know I remember who
do I make this happen uh Javi j-a-v-y
yeah man I appreciate everything 2019
man just moved back to Chicago funds are
running low no work I started flipping
everything documenting it fast forward
to today just bought a four bedroom
house to my girlfriend I just started my
dream job at a marketing agency down the
street I'm proud of you yeah without
your advice man I appreciate it I'd love
to be a small part I literally
real business good for you that's what I
was doing on this side good for you yeah
you came in proper thank you I noticed
it right away
You're So Dope thank you Gary thank you
for you being you honestly I know so
many people tell you this but like I
appreciate and are so grateful for the
text messages and sometimes the random
ones just come okay I know because
they're like real Universal [ __ ] that
I'm feeling at that moment I'm so
grateful thank you Gary thank you so
much stay well everything I have advice
of course yeah how would you find like
your passion in life and what's your
like you know advice
a person missing their life so I think I
think people are
struggle with passion
because they overthink the financial
part of it
so a lot of people's passion is cooking
or video games or gardening or watching
movies but their brain says I can't
build a business watching movies
also it seems like it's always like end
up building a business yeah because when
people ask me Gary what's my passion
they're really asking me Gary what can I
make money on that I also like
am I right and I think that what happens
is people over rationalize the business
part but if you actually focus on the
passion part for real
I love Star Wars I love Legos I love
skateboarding that then when you take a
stick back with content and everything
Now podcast Tick Tock blogs you can make
anything a business anything but you
need to have a thing which you like to
do right I believe that the reason you
have to focus on your passion is if you
love it it doesn't feel like work and if
it doesn't feel like work you can do it
10 12 hours a day which is what's
required to give a business by yourself
a chance to succeed you can't nine to
five yourself to a one percent life yeah
and how to find things you loved and try
I think you know the answer I bet you
she can tell me things you like it's
really all what you told about cooking
games he likes them all you just started
from all all of them Gregory all of them
can be the business but you don't think
it can
and then you once you realize that then
you start making content and you're like
oh my accent no
I grew up with family the whole time my
parents don't blame their accent nobody
gives a [ __ ] it's even better just gotta
make thanks for hanging in line oh no
yeah no problem of course
um I feel like I don't know it's really
quick I feel like I'm stuck in my work I
got a good job of making a decent amount
of money but like I'm not passionate
about it at all I'm looking working long
hours it's like I'm just stuck and I
don't know what I want to do really yeah
so I think what you do is you really ask
yourself what things most get you going
music Sports food video games I'm gonna
trust selling stuff on Amazon or
anything just so I could just get out
from the job and don't feel over
pressure to quit just yet you're so
young yeah like you're so yeah bro like
you could do this thing for another two
years and be practical and get a
paycheck and then at 28 find the thing
you want yeah so don't put overdue
pressure on yourself to quit now with no
answer with no answer is unacceptable
not fighting to find an answer is
unacceptable no I gotta yeah
you like that one you'd like that that
caught you right that's I thought that
was a good one too I like that because
it's the truth thank you so much stay
well
how are you insane I came this is like
not even real right now but I've been
following you to do some high school
like and as much as it's just insane
finally being with you like lots of
words right now but thank you changed my
life and
um I have followed some other stuff like
I'm a photographer I like to do
photography yes
um and I I've done like the things you
know
uh like I try to do concepts yeah and
you know ahead of people and they said
hey can I yeah you know you're a veteran
I'll do it for free yeah I'll give you
edited pictures this and that and I've
been doing it for quite a while is I've
been doing photography for a year yeah
but I've been blessed because I've been
I've covered many events here in Chicago
I was even at vcon I took some dope
pictures of you
um and hopefully I can be part of the
media team maybe 2023. we're around but
my one of one of the biggest things is
my family they're supportive but they it
is they don't think it's a real job it's
it's more of like okay you're not
getting paid like they every single time
I do an event or something they're like
like let's say I do but it's only been a
year let's say let's say but it's only
been a year and they every single time I
come from an event they're like okay how
much but what how much but why why is
why is there conversation matter in this
equation
uh can you read that again yeah of
course uh what's like why are we valuing
their commentary I guess because my
family thinks I'm wasting my time and
what do you think about what they do
I think like you know I
don't I don't know that's the end of the
story every single time they just ask me
like how much do they pay do they do
they pay for your lifestyle yeah no they
don't and they have no say yeah yeah
it's just it's just a repeating
conversation with them don't have the
conversation
say it nice don't be a dick say it
nicely be like who are we talking about
Mom Dad brother who Grandma I love my
grandma good grandma just grandma Yeah
be like Grandma I [ __ ] love you now
shut your [ __ ] mouth
don't say that but you know what I mean
right be like Grammy I got you I love
you I know you care about me I'm doing
this this is a wrap this is not a combo
[Music]
Grandma I know what I'm doing yeah I've
got time to get paid
the end
I love you
but we're not having this combo no more
that's it sometimes I guess yeah thanks
thanks baby I got you okay it's real
she'll honestly you'll be surprised how
much she respects it
four three two one
beautiful
Grandma's grandmas are gangsters they
are they know you show her conviction
you'd be surprised what happens you show
her softness like you might be right
Grandma then it all gets [ __ ] up yeah
you understand
it's great to see you how you been it's
great to see you again dude it's good to
see you again bro good to see you same
yeah thank you this is so much of course
here we go it was a game changer right
is one word for it brother magical it's
awesome it's something very very very
special thank you bro like I'm seriously
so humble to be a part of it thank you
and just man
I love read the new stuff bro thank you
bro
can I sign something that means a lot to
me bro thanks
um can you write don't care about yeah
um I've been following you from
April and I'm watching a video I know
this you talk a lot about like
conquering fear
um and I just put my job in a
traditional Finance into D5 and good for
you yeah
you're welcome I'm proud of you that's a
big jump yeah I know
um what did your family think about that
um they don't understand but I don't I
don't care about that for you you could
always go back yeah
I know you don't want to I know you
don't want to say that but you can
people don't realize like the most
interesting part of taking the jump and
trying something new
is that the thing that you're leaving is
always [ __ ] there
there's a billion finance jobs yeah good
for you proud of you what is the number
one reason you stopped working with
family
me personally yeah Serendipity my the
first one was my dad you know like my
brother was coming up the game and you
know I would argue I mean in the last 48
hours I had a significant talk about
Vayner Sports and Wine Library so I
don't necessarily I'm not necessarily
out of it a minute day to day but the
first one was I was 34 I felt that I
gave my dad what I needed to give him my
brother was coming up I wanted to work
with him the second one was my brother
left Vayner to start to do Vayner Sports
because he wasn't enjoying it wasn't
feeling well so
I I don't I don't think there's ever a
reason to or not to do business with
family I just think when you know it's
not right or you know it's right you
should do yeah you know what I mean
there's no supposed to it's just you got
to deal with the reality are you in it
yeah I am you may think by not talking
about it you're doing the right thing
for the relationship yeah you're
actually doing the wrong thing for the
relationship every day in your stomach
it's going to build more and more
resentment
think about how you feel now versus two
years ago
now think what's going to be hit in two
years in two years it's going to burn
and eventually you're gonna burst
so before you burst come with love and
empathy for them but but speak your
truth and hope that they can hear it and
if not then at least you know you tried
to do it the right way yeah and I could
ever fall back every time in my life
when I didn't speak to it up front and
held it it didn't work out for me
every time yeah and I'm good at it but
93 leaves seven percent of my life that
I have regrets and sadness and it was
[ __ ] up but that's all you're always
gonna have regrets but the reality is
you just speak to them now before it's
really a problem first delay but come
with love and understanding for them but
speak your truth
because if you wait you're going to come
in hot and it's going to be a mess to
begin with yeah I get you last time I
met you I have an anti-racism non-profit
I remember it very vividly
because you you hit me because it got me
when I left you went after me I remember
my shoulder
you said it's marketing it's branding
they got bad information I double down
I'll be hitting at it
the U.N the actual United Nations I
didn't even know they had a music arm
it's called the international music
Council they reached out to my nonprofit
they said I saw what you're doing on
social seems like we're aligned I've met
with the president of the international
music Council and we're trying to do our
work man yeah
I can't thank you enough he's so proud
of you thank you I give a lot of ideas
but a lot of people don't do anything
about it
I'm so proud of you I remember it like
yesterday
I'm proud of you brother
hope to see you again I can't wait take
care I'm the coins Maddox CEO it's such
a pleasure to be cute what's good it's
so nice to meet you is where I have a
question for you please okay what are
the ingredients to the perfect pitch
because I need to know I'm trying to get
a d we make like you the the I think the
ingredients are deep conviction in your
product okay the con conviction in your
product deep empathy for the person
selling it deep empathy for the person
selling so think about that right
everyone's like I want this from you
Macy's are you worried about what Macy's
worries about so what I do you
understand so I try to reverse engineer
what's important to them that's that
empathy empathy and then finally reps
reps I've asked for things like this 7
300 times
more reps because once they keep
rejecting you you start learning to why
exactly so I'm with Gary Gary within 20
seconds what's your best advice for
people that are just ready to like give
up and they don't know what to do
anymore like they've failed so many
times they're just ready to give up
what's your best advice you're only one
good idea away from having all of that
be past history the thought of giving up
makes absolutely no sense the odds of
being alive is so rare squeeze the [ __ ]
out of the opportunity wow wow that was
amazing
how are you do you remember me from
vikon of course dude you were so hyped
it's so good to see you again it was
crazy I found out that I was going to
Becon from you know the mindful Runner
yes he gave me a ticket I called my
friend we went there my first fight
although my mom was scared out of her
mind such a pleasure to meet you I'll
let him talk first because yes please
yes like when I was 11. yes wanted the
Star Wars bobble heads yeah yes I got
avocados from our backyard my friends
caught them over we climbed the trees we
drove out to the corner screamed up and
down got every single car to stop bypass
yep I did stock trading started a
podcast
interviewed people interviewed kid
entrepreneurs that's all entrepreneurs
then I did content creation without a
whole thing yes another video with you
that was my best ever performing video
thank you
and now I'm doing some nft stuff good
for you I'd love to be friends Community
thank you with that thank you and I just
wanted to ask any advice you have listen
honestly when I hear that when you're a
child and you want something and you're
willing to climb trees and go on the
corner and sell it that's that's what I
come from the advice is the the reason I
push patients so much is the only thing
that can derail you is if you want it
too fast
because you clearly have it in you
already
so that doesn't mean to temper your
ambition or your aspiration or your
tenacity but it's not compromising your
values to be financially successful
patience because you said you said um
thinking slow in the long term but being
faster every day right that's right
macro slow micro fast and on that I
think and I know that I have the ability
to be something big and I want to work
at Vayner and five ten years I'll be
ready I'll be ready do you think it
would be possible to spend a week
shadowing yes I want him to Shadow team
Gary for a week done I'm coming to New
York I'll shout out with someone it's
done I love it thank you you're welcome
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I gotta tell you you've changed my life
I almost died in a motorcycle accident
last year I'm so sorry to hear my neck
my collarbone I got three kids family to
support
your words and inspiration got me out of
my job into nfts I've launched my own
project tiger Queen with Carol Baskin I
think I'd be talked at Solana
and now we're building a database of
endangered animals and captivity and
we've donated 75 000 to charity in the
last few months only because of
you because you executed
every day I'm talking every day you
execute we're doing those you feedback
it makes me so proud of you bro I
appreciate it man I love it bro I want
you to sign my arm
if you could do a dude I'm getting it
tattooed right after this where do you
want it wherever you want to fill in man
if you can Doodle Draw you can have as
much space as you want trying to think
of where the right gets to yeah
can't wait to see it
please send me a tweet of it thanks
everybody following me again the dazz3.e
I know thank you so much man pleasure
brother quit my job
um
yeah six figures yeah now I'm hurting
from me and I can't get a job when I
want to do yeah yeah I would go yeah
because that one isn't emotional it's
practical Financial
and what that's going to do is corrode
your emotional so what you do is you do
go back but in parallel well first of
all you're talking about the exact same
job because they're offering it and
they're giving me more I would say yes
just because you need it for now
hopefully because you did that it might
be better and then also think about why
you were miserable were you not
communicating to them do you just like
you know what I mean you're holding on
some resentment flush it make the more
money and then also restart and equally
in parallel fly the plane while you're
fixing it keep doing it you know becomes
at night instead of all day yeah got it
thanks for your time yeah don't never
let ideology [ __ ] up reality you know
what I mean the theory of like I'm not
going back [ __ ] that you need it if you
need the money money is oxygen for a
human I'm doing well
I need that awesome I was just gonna ask
for the panda but thank you very much
you're welcome brother I didn't sell the
black cat yet I see it
I would hold on to it too Amen to hold
that but I got nervous and forgot
Trucking along yeah good working on
myself good that's the game that's
always the game we all are every day I'm
like in the most unbelievable place and
have been and I'm better than I was two
years ago too it's around accountability
and self-awareness like all of us got
[ __ ] to do this community has made such
a difference in my life it's like
straight positive appreciate you that's
the game plan my man somebody chipped in
for my ticket now let me get here you
know why stop Twitter be friends exactly
appreciate it thanks for making a trip
thank you for doing all the things you
do try it honestly I've told him
multiple times I feel like I get your
text because I signed up for it I like
the perfect times yeah it's like you're
reading my mind I'm very flattered it
just feels like the correct thing to
hear that inside I'm humbled thank you
how are you I'm good Gary man I make
donuts on site fresh if I could do it on
Becon at vcon it would be an honor you
know what what if I don't we have you
know what the problem is Right food
vendors like the licensing and all that
[ __ ] so I don't want to promise that but
do you want to come into vaynermedia in
January and do it in the office
get his info he does Donuts on site I
want to we're all coming back in January
I want to do some fun stuff welcome back
let us see come through and do some
donuts Gary excuse my hand no you do
nothing it's all good thank you got you
there's gratitude
it's like changed my life like for real
because like for me everything just
slowed down once you started focusing
yeah you know what I mean yes I do help
me become more patient yes and
everything just kind of like now I like
look at everything long term and just
yeah there's so much take care of my
life on a daily basis daily basis I'm
just grateful for everything couldn't
agree more that's why I push the [ __ ]
out of it like if you're actually
grateful
it's hard to be upset about dumb [ __ ]
yeah exactly and everything's done
everything and everybody here thinks
everything's important nothing's
important exactly except for your family
that's it Health and Family what the
[ __ ] else by the way real quick and if
your family Situation's [ __ ] up make
new family
that's it Brandon warnicki is my family
I could get some advice please fire away
what's your name Anisha Anisha
go ahead so I am an engineer I'm a
mechanical design engineer and I want to
start a company eventually okay
um I want to choose the world I
literally want to be the Tony Stark of
this world like a good hero I got you
um and I think fear is holding me back I
think of what mess it up or not
happening in front of in front of whom
I don't let myself down if anything yeah
but by not doing you're letting yourself
down by the second
that's not the answer
nobody wants to change the world is
worried about messing up to themselves
there's somebody in your life that is
holding judgment on you that carries
clout on you
who is it
I don't know maybe growing up my mom was
tough on me to be like the best right
that was that was hard right and when
you're taught to be the best you're
scared to do [ __ ] out of the boundaries
because outside the lane of good in
school get engineered job outside of it
that shit's risky you figured out the
lane it's why you're a mechanical
engineer and designing everything is you
just you have to figure it out so if
you're gonna change the [ __ ] world
you got to be in [ __ ] outer space
because there's nobody changing the
[ __ ] world going down the same
Highway if you don't try
if you don't try to do some [ __ ] outside
the lane I have to you're going to
regret it your whole life
foreign
so just do it
like you have to probably talk to your
mom about it
things are different now but definitely
and she's gonna be scared for you right
yeah of course and you love her and you
don't want to scare her or disappoint
her but you're disappointing yourself
definitely and if you disappoint
yourself you're eventually going to be
disappointed at your mom instead of
worrying about disappointing her and
that's worse
I didn't even realize that it was
something that would still be affecting
me of course it is of course it is all
that [ __ ] that we deal with on the come
up it's in there and we gotta [ __ ]
work through it all of us got it all of
us got it
you could do it you're welcome I'm gonna
give you some context
um don't make me lose this uh scared to
lose that thanks for everything like
you're changing people's life in a very
positive way so usually it's the other
way around you'll give people stuff so I
met the guy at V Khan who's Italian he
was Napoli this jacket is from him he
stayed at my place in the Bronx when he
came and that's for you he made it in in
Naples
where they actually produce all those
fancy clothing in there yeah it looks
amazing so this is different that
envelope I gave to him I want to read it
I want to read it from him let's make
sure I don't lose this team this is
[ __ ] fresh look at this
foreign
and this is my present for you I knew
you were watching uh that's my present
for you I heard you liked it I like I
like them a lot yeah that's awesome
brother thank you and last but now
please I met Andy at the Kyle concert
and then he was super nice it was super
nice where is Andy is he here yeah it is
here where's Andy oh we left yeah we'll
get that we'll get this to Andy yeah
you're very sweet and yeah I don't need
a picture I'm here for the moment just
remember my name memo because I'm going
to be your number one blockchain
solution architect soon when the time is
right I can't wait memo all right take
care my friend
please I can't as many as you can
whatever what's your names my name is
David that's Lauren Lauren Lauren where
are you guys from Worcester what part
oh Westchester yeah what part uh Port
Chester Port Chester my brother lives in
Larchmont that's why I was asking yeah
I'm from Poland but I live in
Connecticut very nice so I have given an
opportunity I know this is like not the
right place to do it but there's every
pla every place is the right place
we're gonna get this for Vayner or for
be friends or which one Whatever get
this generous what do you do
um so I go to I'm doing corporate laws
and I work Photoshop well for an agency
with case management with different
population mental and do you want to get
a job within legal it's great we're
hiring there a lot helping people to
like like she's the perfect fit for your
company I believe because she embodies
everything that you preach and if it
wasn't for him I wouldn't have not
anything about you so I'm very excited
I'm so nervous don't be nervous it's so
nice for you guys today was about really
the idea of like the people that you
came up with your family even though
they might have been selling fear and
telling you you can't and be careful in
all this
it's not real
that if you can hear your own voice
in the midst of all of those voices that
carry a lot of clout with a young person
when you're a child your parents the
world their voice is loud
but when you get older it's imperative
to make your voice louder than all of
theirs and that's hard
that's very hard to hear it because she
struggles with that of course so much of
us do we all are biped at some level
every one of us is a byproduct of it and
not all of us are as lucky to have pure
optimism and positivity that's what I
had from her so it was easy you know but
not everybody has that and I mean we're
usually the one that gives out the
positivity but it always happens of
course because you have your own set of
circumstances you know I spend a lot of
time reading it even though it was very
simple just because I wanted to like let
everything marinate and really let it
and once and what if most for you I
would say empathy accountability and
gratitude talk to me about
accountability
nobody takes responsibility for the
accident everybody wants to blame
somebody else exactly it's just in real
life real life happens in relationship
happens with absolutely [ __ ]
everything everything so factors the
fact of the matter is if you start
taking more accountability and taking a
step back and saying what did I have to
after this [ __ ] exactly I could resign
from this job
maybe not
person that
is this like everything can come back to
you always forever
very solid point that an empathy also I
think that was just starting to feel for
others yeah because you've had to go
something in the book about if someone I
think there was an episode of someone
had stole from yeah and so don't let
that make
and or going like down yeah you said let
me take a step back they may be in the
situation it's what ended up happening
by the man the man bird is back at the
store and started to take pain medicine
and that's what made him flip his switch
oh see look at that it's it's real man
let's take his photo so I work for
Macy's but uh when they told me you were
coming here I'm like you gotta get it I
gotta meet this guy everybody's sitting
here and they're like oh yeah you're
talking about him a couple months ago
I'm like I'm not even talking about him
for years like but just a couple things
like
you really changed the way I perceived
the idea of like you know you don't have
to you don't have to be a killer you
don't have to be you know you don't have
to be Machiavelli in business you're not
sure do things like that way you know
the idea of uh you you know you could be
the you could be the star actor in your
own play you could be the director of
your own play that's right why don't you
want an Emmy as a supporting 100 I
believe that right like every day you go
into business I'm like I've spent so
much time I can tell you the first video
I ever watched of you which one was it
yeah so it was you were sitting in like
a little round table with a couple of
business guys and uh uh people and uh
someone was telling you about like how
come my team doesn't work as hard as I
do and you're like how many people you
got you said 40 like I wish I had four
to do like that worked for me and you
said let me ask you a question what I
would do is I would go breakfast lunch
and dinner for the next four weeks I
meet every single one of them see what
motivates it all right so it makes them
tick and like that gave me a lot to
understand that the more you invest in
people and you stop thinking about
Capital your time as money you think
about your time Capital you know you
want passive income right you want your
money to be working when you're not
working you invest your hours you invest
your time people are going to work for
you 100 right Steward of their of their
dreams they'll be a steward of your
thoughts the level of selfishness is
absurd as if these people's lives are
predicated to me it's insane for me
every day when I work with them I'm like
why is this good for them right I don't
understand how people don't understand
that at the end of the day I hope that
people look at me and they say you know
you cared you tried 100 do the best that
I can all that and so I just think that
like you're a big part of that that
means a lot to me and I think you I
think you post awesome content out there
thank you I'm not I don't know enough
about the nft space yeah I'm good with
that but there's there's the garyvee
that's before the nft the Gap part of me
is like animals jumping but well that
part the garyvee thing it was was there
before when only those three people knew
who I was yeah like new technologies
don't change anything it's all the same
like this IP is being built on the
blockchain right into physical right but
being a genuine human being
is the punch line yeah yeah I love it
it's awesome thank you brother yeah it
means a lot to me
thank you